all right perhaps one of the most
visually dazzling demos of the night was
batman arkham knight this trailer just
looks incredible all I could hear was
like sighs of pleasure and the word
particles being mumbled occasions
direction well I wasn't sure I mean
because basically we it's not actually
confirmed as far as I know specifically
what version of Unreal Engine this is
running on I think it's three I looked
it up right in the brain three it might
be that the the width 3.51 that they did
with the Samaritans I know the one that
that star wars game was going to be 0 1
30 and 30th ruminating 30 or something
yeah the one that got cancelled yeah 13
yes 1313 and so that that sort of had a
lot the stuff remember on your fault in
them in a real engine 3 I said that
specifically the particle effects
because that's something that they've
been hammering home for like ages which
one are like hey particle is they're
great I mean this the draw distance is
here look amazing like lighting and
everything slicing like it just looks so
good and then at this point Danny I
believe it was you said why would you
use the Batmobile when you can just do
this hide it and fly around the whole
place yeah parent I don't think it
showed it here but I've heard that
apparently with the Batmobile if you
like jump over a building and you come
down the other side the Batmobile like
straight-up drives around the building
for you and you cannot begin again oh
yeah like traversal I don't know it's
always been pretty good in this series
but with the scale of this world and
especially the verticality and it seems
like you're pretty easy to get around
look at this destructibility I'm just
plowed right through that and the chunks
are flying a little bit later on in this
demo we see that pebble wheel can stream
it was a bit of a show to see but you
know it looks cool I guess that's a
really easy way of getting around the
problem with car is getting stuck on
places it's just like make them straight
i'll be able to straight like you can't
really use a car in combat unless you're
doing it like jousting style driving to
work to show that when you turn to the
ousting again so yeah this definitely I
think a smart concession to certainly
play a bill or flexibility and
playability of
batmobile here of course Batman Arkham
Knight delayed recently until 2015 they
really are you know this one is for xbox
one ps4 pc only so they're really trying
to amp up the size of Arkham City in
this game and it's looking very good